hi Fabby thank you so much for joining
me today uh can you tell me a little bit
about your chess upbringing yeah it
started when I was pretty young I was
around 5 years old uh and I was living
in New York at the time uh so it started
after school with other kids from uh
from the chess club it was a very very
small Club very few uh players very few
kids were interested in chess but we had
good coaches and uh my first two coaches
I remember from those early days as well
um Bruce pondini and Miran Sher who
sadly passed away a few years ago but
they were like very instrumental in my
early coaching and very prominent in the
New York circles so a lot of the kids I
grew up with also became very strong
players like uh Robert Hess is is of
course a houseold name he was one of the
one of my competitors when I was a kid
and also one of my friends and Mark
Arnold and other other players from the
New York area became either very strong
players or grand Masters so it was a
really good scene chesting to grow up in
uh and of course the the Marshall chess
club is is famous as like one of the
oldest chess clubs in in the world and
um dedicated to Frank Marshall in in New
York so it was really good to like grow
up in that atmosphere and being being
able to play strong players even as a as
a kid to play uh International Masters
or fed Masters or players of of quite a
strong level uh in my kind of early
formative years as a chess player so
that was my upbringing and after that of
course uh I had to at some point make a
branch between school and chess I had to
make that decision so I made that
decision pretty young and and from there
I became maybe not professional but
started my path towards becoming a
professional chess player how many hours
would you say you were spending on chess
studying various things early on it was
probably I didn't have much incentive on
my own I like to play but I didn't like
to study so if we count pure study then
it was probably like 2 hours a week just
working with my coaches I'm talking
about like when I was still in school
and playing I I did play pretty much
every day uh every evening after school
my dad would drive me to the Marshal
Marshall chess club and uh and we would
play there and then when I stopped going
to school then I was working on my own
quite significantly those were still in
the days where computers weren't too
strong so I think a lot that was very
important as well that I got that
experience of working over the board on
my own um and I I was very interested in
it in it I think if I hadn't had the
interest that I
developed say when I was 12 until my
late teenage years then I probably
wouldn't have gotten quite so strong I
don't think I would have improved so
easily but I had an interest that was
very strong during those years and that
really helped me a lot because I I could
apply myself for hours and hours every
day so from like 12 till let's say until
I became like a strong Grand Master like
16 17 I I was working a few hours every
day and when you say working you mention
that you had a few hours with your
coaches and then you worked on your own
was there a specific book that uh you
remember now that has had an impact on
your chess career yeah I remember a lot
of books I'm not sure which one I would
say has like a very strong impact but
all of them like gave me something and
and I do remember um like I I I worked a
lot with John Watson's books when I was
in like those early teenage years and I
would like go through the examples of
course it's hard to say now like how
much of that knowledge would hold up to
engine analysis but I think just the
process of working on your own is is
already very beneficial even if let's
say the all the uh all the stuff that
you look at isn't correct that's not the
main part the main part is just that
you're applying yourself and you're
thinking critically about Chess and that
that's going to lead to Improvement so
uh definitely the material I looked at a
lot of uh John Watson's books a lot of
Jonathan Ron's books um of course
kasparov's books uh and there were some
old classics that I also worked with
quite a lot and and with coaches uh a
lot of like studies I remember when I
was working with cherin for about 2
years he would uh give me like entire
palbo studies which would take sometimes
2 hours to fully go through and just sit
there and calculate things from
beginning to end so I do remember
sitting and looking at like one position
for let's say 2 hours straight um yeah
of course a lot of that is is like very
wrote work but it really can can make a
difference when you're when you're
improving especially when you're young a
lot of those ideas sink in a lot of the
like um thought process that you work on
sinks in during your games I love how
you said that even if specific books
don't hold up maybe to the engines these
days they still have a big impact in the
development of a person people sometimes
forget about that and it's very
important to have a strong player like
yourself mention those things because
working on your own it's it's really
something that's building up a strong
understanding yeah yeah I think that's
the most important thing cuz sometimes
we focus on like you work half an hour
on a position and you find out that the
the book was wrong cuz let's say it was
written before computer times and
they're going to make mistakes and then
you think this whole process was
worthless but in fact I think that just
because you were sitting there
calculating is more worthwhile than
whatever like let's say objective value
of the position was of course and you're
coming in this year as the champ ion do
you feel any pressure um getting into
this competition considering that you
have to switch from classical chest to
Rapid 9lx do you feel any pressure for
this particular event to bring back the
championship I think normal amounts of
pressure because every year it's pretty
much a tossup like anyone could
potentially win so I don't feel like um
like let's say all the pressure is on me
I think the pressure is kind of evenly
split among players who who all have
their hopes of winning and yeah very
often it comes down to um who's just
who's just uh on the best form during
the tournament so I me we have guys like
Levon and Wesley and lenier uh and also
the the younger players are very
promising very dangerous now they're
growing up a bit so they're kind of
maturing more in their chess approach um
we saw like seon was um was very
impressive in 9lx
um but also Jeffrey and and Ray and all
these players are very capable so I
don't feel like I have so much pressure
on me compared to other players I think
everyone will be dealing with this a bit
and also the last very serious
tournament I played the World Cup uh I
don't think that the pressure is going
to compare to that that's a bit more
because it's like a knockout and more um
riding on a single game or a single move
that this pressure is is probably going
to be a bit more uh Pleasant compared to
that well thank you Fabiana thank you
very much I wish you good luck and
looking forward to seeing your games
thank
[Music]
you